y centenares de muertos y desaparecidos
pueblos devastados y las peores
tormentas e inundaciones en décadas
afectó especialmente a alemania y
bélgica pero expertos avisan de que
estos desastres se repetirán los
impactos del cambio climático seguirán
empeorando mientras enviamos gases de
efecto invernadero a la atmósfera lo que
significa que durante las próximas tres
décadas todo esto empeorará y tenemos
que aprender a enfrentarlo mejor los
efectos del cambio climático han dejado
olas de calor inéditas en distintas
partes del mundo el lunes 28 de junio
canadá estableció la temperatura más
alta de su historia llegando a los 40 y
79 grados celsius decenas de personas
murieron y los analistas avisan de que
el verano solo acaba de empezar el creo
que decir que tengo mucho miedo de lo
que estos hechos auguran para el resto
del verano estos eventos extremos el año
pasado no ocurrieron hasta finales de
agosto y septiembre
unas olas de calor que están provocando
graves incendios esto es california en
eeuu y estos iberia en rusia
en el círculo polar ártico donde han
ardido más de un millón de hectáreas
estos incendios están ocurriendo en
lugares donde hay olas de calor y largas
sequías estos sucesos a alimentar la
inflamabilidad del campo
más allá de las inundaciones olas de
calor e incendios científicos avisan de
que el cambio climático va a traer otros
efectos como el aumento del nivel del
mar así como grandes sequías eventos que
provocarán trastornos sociales masivos
entre los que destacarán grandes
desplazamientos de personas